all right humans and humanoids we are
live on rumble blaze tv and youtube i'm
dave rubin we've got another round table
panel extravaganza
to recap the week that was joining me
today is the host of the morning wire
podcast over at the daily wire ethan
hawthorne the host of the news and why
it matters on blaze tv sarah gonzalez
and the ceo and editor-in-chief of
beckernews.com
kyle becker ian sarah kyle welcome to
the reuben report
thanks for having me having us thank you
all right we've got two first-time
guests sarah is an old veteran of the
reuben report uh we're gonna recap this
crazy week every week is crazy but uh
this week seemed particularly crazy
because here in florida i was told by
the mainstream media and blue check
people on twitter that you can't say
gay
now i just said gay i'm here in florida
nobody seems to be coming to get me but
that's the thing anyway everyone knows
about this we've been covering it all
week there's this bill that basically uh
stops teachers from talking to
kindergartners to third graders about
gender identity or sexuality they can't
hide those conversations from the
parents it's all very obvious stuff that
any sane person would agree with
however of course everyone's calling
this the don't say gay bill they're
gonna you know kill gay people and it's
gonna be all very horrible and scary ron
desantis is just standing up and he is
fighting he had a sit down with the ceo
of disney who was going to slap him over
the wrist and desantis just completely
went on the attack we've got some video
of ron desantis after the ceo of disney
tried to smack him down on this thing
so here's what i can tell you uh in the
state of florida
we are not going to allow them to inject
transgenderism into kindergarten
first graders shouldn't have uh woke
gender ideology imposed in their
curriculums and that is what we're
standing for because we're standing for
the kids and we're standing for the
parents uh and i can tell you this there
the chance that i am going to
back down from my commitment to students
and back down from my commitment to
parents rights
simply because of fraudulent media
narratives or pressure from woke
corporations the chances of that are
zero
when you have companies that have made a
fortune off being family friendly and
catering to families and young kids you
know they should understand
that parents of young kids do not want
this injected into their kids
kindergarten classroom they do not want
their first graders to go and be told
that they can choose an opposite gender
that is not appropriate for those kids
and so if you're family friendly
understand
the parents who are actually raising
families want to have their rights
respected and i also think that if you
have companies like a disney that are
going to say and criticize parents
rights they're going to criticize the
fact that we don't want transgenderism
and kindergarten and first grade
classrooms if that's the hill that
they're going to die on then how do they
possibly explain
lining their pockets with their
relationship from the communist party of
china and so in florida
our policy is going to be based on the
best interest of florida citizens not on
the musing of preparation
[Applause]
man you know i've been saying it all
week but every time i play a clip of
desantis it's like you can breathe
freely it's like oh truth truth actually
exists honesty actually exists brave
people
actually exist uh sarah i want to start
with you here because i saw a random
person an anonymous person on twitter
this week called you a homophobe
when you were discussing this as far as
i know you're not a homophobe uh but how
great to see someone actually standing
up against this nonsense
yeah dave uh you know it's interesting
because desantis i see this as a native
texan right born and raised in texas
texas is supposed to be known as this
bastion of freedom and liberty and yet
desantis is completely out texas in
texas uh it's so crazy to see his ascent
knowing how far he's come in such a
short amount of time didn't he almost
lose to a meth addict i mean yes it was
like not even a percentage point like he
was he almost lost to that guy and he
seems to have red-pilled almost the
entire state now because i think he's
learned what all of these corporations
have not yet learned which is just
because these people just because these
leftists radicals scream the loudest
does not mean that they represent the
majority of americans we saw it in the
governor's race in virginia we saw it in
deep blue san francisco when they had
their school board members recalled i
mean we are seeing this all across the
country because the leftist radicals are
so radical they don't know anything to
do but double down on this crazy talk
like we should have pornography in
schools
imagine fighting for pornography in
schools uh we should we should be
teaching sex to children we should be
teaching them sexual positions these are
things that parents are not going to
stand for and luckily ron desantis knows
that
and he's certainly fighting for them i
just have to say i understand why you
moved there dave i am very embarrassed
right now as a texan that ron desantis
and florida are leading the way uh when
it comes to freedom and liberty and this
is just one of the many examples
listen i never thought that my house
would have to be a refuge for people
from texas but i've got a couple extra
guest rooms you are welcome anytime
ian i appreciate it ian you try at the
daily wire you guys try to honestly
assess the news and give people really
what's going on one of the strange
things about this one is if you read the
text of the bill which we've covered on
my show all week and i'm sure you're
covering as well it has the word gay is
not in there this is completely about
being transparent with what kids are
learning at schools and not hiding what
teachers might be talking about with
first graders from parents are you
amazed at just the way the media gets
away with this over and over again it's
just the meme is that this is the don't
say gay bill and this is somehow all
about bigotry and homophobia
well it's just shameless the way the
entire media literally the entire media
has rallied around the don't say gay
name which is just completely
representative of what the bill actually
does but they do this with almost
everything just the fact that they call
abortion and pro-choice
everything about the left is really just
how they frame certain issues
ticket that if you oppose that issue you
oppose something drastic the same with
black lives matter the idea that if you
opposed the idea that police were
systemically uh brutal across the
country you were therefore racist you
believe black people didn't matter which
is of course absurd and so i'm not
really shocked that the media is doing
this i'm sure that people are just so
lazy they don't even google read the
bill all of this stuff is available
online you can just find it gay isn't
mentioned the fact that people are going
around charting gay as if that's going
to undo the evil that is desantis and
his legislation is just ridiculous but
indicative of where we are right now
kyle jumping off that point i've wanted
to have you on the show for a while
because you're one of the guys on
twitter that i follow that is like
you're hitting the media the right way
and trying to expose some of this
nonsense do we need better tactics in
exposing this i mean something did
happen i think this week where it was so
obvious
that that that what they were doing was
so dishonest that i do think we woke up
some people but it's never enough and
it's never fast enough right yeah well i
think there's been a big shift between
the political left and right and so you
have to see if it's out there he did he
sounded like america's governor he
sounded very much like a concerned dad
on this issue which i think really
worked for him and
you know it used to be that the populist
left was excited about politicians
standing up to big corporations well ron
desantis has actually done yes not only
in this case with disney but with big
tech remember he signed that bill that
you know google and uh meta and twitter
can't d platform florida political
candidates or they'll be fined 250 000 a
day uh so i think like he has gotten a
lot of street cred with independence
center-right uh and no matter how much
the mainstream media squeal at ron
desantis right now he is cutting through
the noise with the statements where he's
very
uh focused and he's speaking to parents
and he's speaking to uh you know just
people who are concerned about what's
going on in the schools and i think we
saw that in virginia you could flip a
state like that so i think that you know
with the with the woke left
they're really in dangerous territory
right now with all of these lies because
i think desantis you know
he sounds very rock steady and sure and
i think people are it's going to
resonate with independents no matter
what the mainstream media says at this
point so i think his leadership is is
really
is really uh
really much needed and it's helping to
cut through the media noise sarah do you
think that's the silver lining here that
they went so all in on something that
was just so dishonest you know i've met
desantis a few times like the guy is not
a homophobe this is this is literally
about not having state employees talk to
children about sex and then hide it from
the parents uh is the silver lining that
that that is being now modeled or
hopefully will be modeled what desantis
is doing and can maybe even make people
in texas braver can make people
certainly in california braver like we
have this mass bravery deficit and maybe
people will look at him and be like hey
he's doing it and they haven't taken him
out yet although obviously they're going
to continue to try
yeah no i completely agree um i i'm
actually really excited about the left
picking this battle with desantis
because
parents all across the country i think
that they can agree on these principles
and as long as the parents are seeing it
injected into their schools they're
seeing who is for it and who is against
it uh the leftists will continue picking
this battle all across the country and
it is a battle that they will lose so
i'm actually very excited for them to
show their true colors there i do think
that parents are going to stand up i
think that governors and local
government officials are going to stand
up because they've seen desantis do it
so successfully
ian i'm going to let you pimp out a
daily wire product here because as the
disney ceo goes after him and and
desantis made the good point it's like
these guys are in bed with the chinese
communists um there are other
alternative entertainment platforms
being developed daily wire is doing a
heck of a job i think there's a new kids
movie coming out this week if i'm not
mistaken
yeah the hyperions it came out last
night so everyone should definitely go
check it out i think it's also showing
that there is a market for this there is
a market for non-woke content and i i
honestly it's great for outlets like the
daily wire that there is a market for
that but on a broader term i think we
all need to be hoping to dial back the
politics a little bit that there is a
market for that people clearly want it
and i'm i'm not too sure the left are
going to wake up and see it though and
hopefully they won't before 20-24
because i think there's a huge
opportunity for us to
hold a mirror up to people like joe
biden and karma harris and make
political wins on the basis of that
kyle i'll give you the last word on this
one um in terms of the media coverage on
this when when all of the mainstream
media runs with the don't say gay meme
again gay is not in the bill
at all and you see the videos of the
florida democrats all screaming gay and
putting tape in their mouth and putting
gay on it it's like there are clubs in
west hollywood you've got to pay people
to do that for you it's like
what
what not that i've i've never been to
those clubs uh but the point is um
do we have enough juice do we have
enough juice in a time of algorithms and
and de-boosting and all that to expose
it well i think desantis showed that the
other day when he had an epic showdown
with a wfla reporter who tried to
confront him about the don't say gay
legislation then uh you know i know this
subject is near to your heart because
you you were even able you know willing
to turn in your gay card over this
that's funny but desantis
asking this reporter if he had read the
bill and he kept dodging the question
and i think he utterly humiliated him
and you know images and video
cut through the noise because it's it's
you could come at it from any angle and
he really put him in this place without
yeah and justifiably so i think desantis
gave him the opportunity to to shoot
straight report what's going on
be accurate be trustworthy and he just
refused to do it because the narrative
is more important than the truth to
these people and i think desantis is
able to deftly expose that and i think
that
americans have stopped trusting the
mainstream media so if anybody is just
able to shoot straight be confident
uh believe in their conviction then i
think that they're they're going to be a
winner they're going to be a lightning
rod and that that's where politics is
heading especially in this 2022
election coming up yeah we played that
clip with the reporter asking him the
question and he turns to the guy
basically and he's like how about you
tell me what's in the bill like he has
just
he has just had it with these people all
right let's move on to the to the other
big story of the week uh we're not going
to do too much on the the war itself
although you guys can feel free to bring
up whatever you want obviously but let's
just talk about the energy situation at
home and gas prices let's throw this
image up from cbs la this is the city
that i fled that mobile station was on
the corner of uh
not the last house i lived in the
previous one the gas prices are
completely
insane 7 35
for regular unleaded gas really nuts uh
but don't worry guys we've got jen saki
on the case here's this little video
that she put out to calm us down you may
have noticed this week that your gas
prices have gone up i want to talk to
you a little bit about why a lot of it
has to do with vladimir putin
the reality is that russia is one of the
three largest oil producers in the world
and the fact that they have started this
conflict invaded a foreign country and
they are such a big producer of oil in
the world is the reason why the global
oil markets are disturbed right now and
why your gas prices are going up and so
to that point inflation goes up today
the president's statement blames the
putin price hike are you guys just going
to start blaming putin for everything
until the midterms well we've seen the
price of gas go up at least 75 cents
since president putin lined up troops on
the border of ukraine
oh solis jensaki just lying and lying
and lying about everything uh my guys
did a little research here we've got
researchers too gas
from the day that joe biden took uh
office so the day that he was
inaugurated until the day that putin uh
went into ukraine went up a dollar
fourteen so yes it's gone up since but
it was going up the entire time kyle was
there something
help me here was there something that
joe biden did right when he got into
office that might have uh did he stop
something that might have helped with
this situation there's something i keep
i had papers here was there something i
think there was something well i think
he pretty much gave us all a warning
when the first thing he did was jump
onto the paris accords and adopted this
this crazy uh you know carbon zero
strategy which is basically about as
futile as the uh it's covet zero
strategy that we've seen you know
attempted to be implemented around the
world uh we saw it with the the federal
leases uh situation is pretty
interesting a lot of drillers are
complaining they can't get the capital
lending that they need in order to do
this drilling there are some bottlenecks
in the regulatory framework that he's
imposed and of course the keystone xl a
pipeline which is bottlenecked the
transit that to get to the refineries
that are on the gulf coast that allow us
to you know refine our own gasoline
which helps bring the prices down uh on
the margins but i think overall
jen is just you know being her own usual
devilish self and sort of creating this
sort of cloud in people's minds but the
fact is that you know like you saw at
the on the hollywood sign it's now
higher than the gasoline was in the
apocalyptic film i am legend with will
smith it was only 671 a gallon there so
i think biden's pregnancy is making us
pine to live in dystopian fiction at
this point
and that's pretty much fiction is all
that gensake has to pedal at this point
it's not putting food on the table it's
not putting gasoline in our tanks so
it's pretty much uh empty gruel to to
dish out to the plebes uh that she's
offered this point i think that normal
people are tuning her out uh it's not
going to fly at the dinner table and
it's not going to fly in the upcoming
elections
that is a great reference man did they
show you the the prices right at the
beginning when they show you that sort
of dystopia in new york city they have
like an image of it is that where you're
grabbing that from yeah yeah 671 in the
clip you can you can find it there's
like a little meme thing floating around
you can find it i i will take your word
on that um ian
is there anything we could be doing to
helping right now is there anything that
biden's not doing that might help i
think uh kyle might have alluded to
something
yeah i think the only thing we can do is
start getting some republicans in office
honestly i mean
biden has been a disaster both on the
foreign policy front but also the energy
front since he came in talked about the
paris climate of course talked about
closing the keystone xl pipeline but on
a higher level every single one of his
solutions involves green energy which
europe has showed is not a solution the
solution is under us right now is the
fact that the united states as of 2016
is sitting on the most untapped oil in
the world we have the solution beneath
our feet but people like biden are too
busy sucking up to the green energy
crowd to really acknowledge that and i
think in some ways the war between
russia and ukraine with russia invading
ukraine is somewhat of a blessing for
biden economically because now with
kovid not an excuse anymore cobit is
over and has been over for a while they
have another excuse because the price
has
been increasing month on month since he
came into office inflation is at record
rates and so this is just a very very
public thing that biden can point to and
blame and of course when it comes down
eventually if he's still in office he'll
take credit for that he's very very good
at taking credit for good things whether
he's responsible or not and blaming
others and so the fact that it's a putin
price hike is absurd also democrative of
the earlier issue where the media has
embraced this messaging that it's the
putin pride hike which of course is not
right putin price hike that's the meme
just like don't say gay became the meme
they just manufacture these things that
are not true and then everyone just
repeats and repeats it sarah could you
allow me to
toss up a conspiracy theory here and you
tell me
completely insane i know you work with
that steve diesel over there who's
always throwing out those crazy wild
conspiracy theories over at the blaze
like you know this great reset or some
of these things
but my feeling is these people could not
possibly be this inept i don't think
they could be this inept and my belief
is actually that everything that the two
guys here just laid out about keystone
and not giving permits and all this
stuff is intentional that they are
two-fold i would say trying to
upend the world energy system and
basically destroy america like i i
actually honestly believe that at this
point am i completely crazy will i be
booted free from youtube for saying that
no well i mean i can't speak for youtube
but uh i mean i can tell you that all of
the evidence points to that right
because you have them making these uh
epic levels of propaganda government
propaganda videos trying to have the
white house press secretary who is a
professional liar come in and explain to
people why it is that gas prices are
rising when people i mean
i understand some americans are a little
i would say disconnected from reality
but i don't think that americans have
that short of a memory that they don't
realize that before all of this was
going on two months ago three months ago
they were paying more at the pump they
were paying more at the grocery store
they're paying more for everything i
don't think that they have such short
attention spans that they don't remember
that but more importantly
we heard joe biden in the last
presidential debate say that he was
going to transition from the oil and gas
sector from the oil and gas industry he
said it and remember we all all the
republicans sat there and watched it and
went oh my gosh he said the quiet part
out loud there's no way he gets past
that he has to be toast
and then as we know how it turned out he
is the most popular president of all
time 81 million votes uh the most secure
election that we've ever had but he was
saying these things he was telling us
that he was going to do these things
it's a wonder to me that he doesn't want
to take the credit because as kamal
harris said you know you get what you
vote for meaning uh we're doing all of
these things that we said we were going
to do and he is so i think you're right
dave i think the answers were right in
front of us they told us what they were
going to do now that they're doing it uh
they don't like the the criticism they
don't like the the uh the the pain that
americans are feeling not because they
care about americans but because they
know it makes them look bad and they
want to continue their power
crazy conspiracy theory indeed put the
tinfoil hat right on me
last thought on this right before we
started i mean literally 30 seconds
before we started this live stream i saw
that biden was giving a speech and he
has announced we are banning imports of
russian vodka so we are going to i mean
think about the stupidity of this is
just so off the charts that okay we're
going to attack and harm our importers
the people that work here in the united
states the exporters in russia who are
just decent businessmen making vodka
it's just extraordinarily stupid but
we've got to move on to the third topic
uh the big thing yesterday was that
jesse smollette who
created a fake
hate crime against himself by hiring two
guys to put a noose around his neck and
there was a subway sandwich and it was a
whole thing and basically the media fell
for it hook line and sinker it proved
that we are a systemically racist city
country and everything else it turns out
that uh none of it happened and he's
going to jail so that's pretty great uh
here's video of him being sentenced and
his little outburst
i'm fashioning the following sentence
and here's your sentence
i'm sentencing you to 30 months spell
felony probation and the probation is
going to be to this court
you will pay restitution to the city of
chicago in the amount of 120 106
you are fined
25 000
which is the maximum fine and you will
spend
the first 150 days of your sentence in
the cook county jail and that will start
today right here right now
no i would just like to say to your
honor that i
i am not suicidal
that's what i was practicing okay i'm
not suicidal okay i am not
suicidal i am innocent and i am not
suicidal
if i did this then it means that i stuck
my fist in the fears of black americans
in this country for over 400 years and
the fears of the lgbtq community your
honor i respect you and i respect the
jury but i did not do this and i am not
suicidal and if anything happens to me
when i go in there i did not do it to
myself and you must all know that
i respect you your honor i respect your
decision
jail time
i am not suicidal okay
wow i mean what you've got right there
is a liar and a huckster and i'm pretty
sure he's telling everybody that he's
about to kill himself in jail because he
wants a further conspiracy theory or
something else i mean that's seriously
psychologically depressing and whatever
else uh before i jump to you guys there
was a gajillion
we roughly estimated that number
gajillion blue check politicians actors
etc etc when this originally happened
saying how this proves that america is
systemically racist and everything
defiant else caught this one from our
wickedly brilliant vice president
this is way back when when the first
thing broke jesse smallett is one of the
kindest most gentle human beings i know
i'm praying for his quick recovery this
was an attempted modern day lynching no
one should have to fear for their life
because of their sexuality or color of
their skin we must confront this hate of
course nancy pelosi also had one of
these and aoc had one of these and just
all the usual suspects and of course you
can see the hill headline below that he
got suspect uh
prosecuted for the 150 days in jail for
faking the hate crime um
ian i'll start with you on this a
certain amount of people are just
they're not going to accept what reality
is on this one huh
i mean once you've doubled down though
you might as well i'll keep doubling
down because that was his whole goal the
whole time what i really want to say
though is that 150 days is not that much
for the consequences of what he
was accusing someone of let's just say
there was a miracle and two white men
were walking around downtown chicago
sub-zero temperatures with maggot hats
on and they were arrested do you think
jesse smellette would have come out and
said no i made the whole thing up or do
you think they would be in jail right
now for decades like he could have
ruined real people's lives and 150 days
is really not that much of a slap on the
wrist in my mind i think it's it's
really appalling that you can play with
people's lives you can ruin people's
lives the risk reward here is just not
correct
yeah kyle what do you make of the
outburst at the end i mean first off
still saying that he didn't do it i mean
everyone knows that he did it this is
not this is not up for debate at this
point but then the really bizarre
suicide thing i mean just sort of going
for the ultimate victim play like he was
a fake victim now going for the ultimate
victim play and obviously i don't want
the guy to kill himself but you can sort
of see where this thing feels like it's
going is is he suicidal i mean he kind
of left some doubt in my mind well if
this was jesse's smallest edition uh
audition to get back on a network show i
think he's gonna have to take some
correspondence courses while he's in
jail uh maybe get a couple of nigerian
guys to to coach him on uh through it uh
you know because he's the only thing he
was missing was like a fans like oh i'm
getting the vapors or maybe the fred
sanford uh oh look out this is the big
one
uh you know it was really
cringe-worthy and awkward and pathetic
and uh you know i think
it's kind of the you know colin
kaepernick syndrome and all of this
stuff you know
the more the more that they you know
clown themselves out in front of the
american public the stronger they get
because the woke left they eat it up so
much but at the end of the day i i just
think that you know whether it's pelosi
or biden or harris jumping onto this
it's it's not because his story is true
it's just that the narrative is the one
that they want to spread it's a useful
myth as sorel uh called it uh it's it's
something that furthers the democratic
party's cause and nobody who who pushes
useful myths uh is punished in the
culture or is punished uh punitively in
our criminal system in america anymore
so i think it's a it's a sign that
really we're we're swimming in this sort
of uh
cultural marxist environment where
these radical leftists are rewarded no
matter how much they lie no matter how
much they defraud the american public uh
you know if they're grifters they can
get rich yeah i mean it's it's really
you know we need to change the culture
if we're going to change the the
politics and the justice in this country
so
um i i i think it's it's you know it's
something that that's very important for
us on the right to to think about and
you know daily wire i saw you know doing
stuff like that in the entertainment
field and everything we need to do we
need to do more of that on the right
because
uh
because because what jesse smulled is
done to this country is is like
deliberate vicious and uh
and it's really dangerous and it's
caused a lot of grievances and
and and it's really
um made the the legitimate grievances of
people who are affected by racism seem
uh you know it's diminished that yeah so
actually let's let's stick with that
sarah i'll give you the final word on
this and then we've got to jump um
in terms of the culture part of this
because i think i think we probably all
agree kyle is right that we have to win
this culture war you know of course
politics is downstream from culture
andrew breitbart all of that um
is it starting to shift i mean we
started with the don't say gay thing and
it's like a lot of people are seeing the
nonsense for what it is a certain amount
of people will wake up and be like boy i
i really fell for that jesse smellet
hoax what else do you think we can do to
to shift the game
i mean i think that we need to continue
uh calling out all of this nonsense for
what it is continuing to draw attention
to the left's hypocrisy i think the the
barometer the real barometer that we
have coming up obviously is the midterms
uh and seeing what happens there uh you
know
despite any you know uh
attempts to
change the votes but uh i think that
that's all that we can do we can
continue fighting fire with fire i think
for so long conservatives were so uh
stuck with you know what i don't like
what's going on outside of my house but
i'm i work for a living i have my family
i keep to myself i just want government
out of my business and i'm just going to
stay within uh the confines of my own
bubble i think that we are seeing that
we cannot do that anymore we have to get
out we have to get involved we have to
get involved at local levels get
involved with your school board we have
to be calling out all of this hypocrisy
and nonsense every single day and
drilling it into these people because
they've been doing all of this for so
long they are professional uh you know
instigators they have infiltrated all of
these organizations and we have to be
able to uh to fight back and really get
active about calling these things out
because you know you may think that they
scream the loudest and the squeaky wheel
gets the grease but i don't think that
that's always the case so hopefully the
barometer of the midterms will end up
showing us that we are on the right
course or more so that the leftists are
on the wrong one
amen sister all right well it was a
pleasure having the three you guys on
i'll gladly have you back if you will
join me and i'm gonna finish up for a
minute or two without you so have a good
weekend and thanks again for joining
today
thanks dave thanks dave
all right guys i am jumping over to the
uh megan kelly show is that live i'm
doing it no it's not live so i got to do
that in a minute but it is not live
it'll be up a little bit later today but
i just wanted to end with one thought
because it was the driving thought of
sort of everything i did all week and i
think sarah actually kind of hit on it
right there at the end
it's time to be braver it's time to be
very very we should have been braver a
long time ago we all should have been we
all should have been saying no to this
nonsense but that speech that desantis
gave in front of those families after
meeting with the disney ceo um that's
the right message no more of this
[ __ ] we are going to stand up we are
going to fight we're going to tell the
truth and we're not even sure what we're
afraid of right like it could not have
been fun for ron desantis to have to be
brought into the office of the disney
ceo this guy has extraordinary power
extraordinary influence extraordinary
money and somehow seems more important
than the governor of a state but we are
not owned by corporations yet and and
desantis said no
no you're a hypocrite your company is
full of hypocrites you work with the
worst sort of people and we're not going
to let you abuse our kids and he said it
clearly and cleanly and man that's what
we need so he's modeling it as the
governor i think florida is modeling as
a state and if we can all model it in
our own lives a little bit more
i think maybe we can win this thing
that's my thought before the weekend i
hope you have a nice weekend and you
don't spend too much time on politics
and the misery of social media uh guys
if you have not yet and it's in many
ways very much about what i just said uh
don't burn this country comes out on
april 12th you can pre-order it right
now at daverubin.com
book part three of my interview with
nikki haley is up on youtube and rumble
and of course ad free over
reubenport.locals.com
and now i am taping megyn kelly which
will air a little bit later this
afternoon happy friday have a good
weekend see you monday